okay so chapter 32 is bringing together
two movements that are kind of connected
with each other and you should be able
to see how they're connected with each
other as we go through this what we call
liberalism in Protestantism liberal
Protestantism sometimes these are called
today the mainline churches and then
social gospel and this term liberal is
one that we we're talking about before
and it's got a lot of uses in today's
politics if you call so many liberal
it's sort of a dirty word in many
circles and some people want to avoid it
and you sort progressives it means
something different overseas of course
some people actually pointed that out
you know I know that's the case that
liberal actually means what we call
conservative in certain respects if
you're over it in France or Germany the
social gospel is going to be something
that's actually going to come out of
this particular emphasis now when we use
this term liberal we want to ask the
question liberal in comparison to what
and usually what's the term that we
counter pose to liberal conservative
yeah so I know if you want me really
clever or smart behave you are you know
really into history of political science
you'll say well you know liberals
originally met what we nowadays call
conservatives that both part of the
grand liberal tradition you know coming
out of John Locke and that's what sort
of business but what do we mean when we
say conservative don't just think like
you know hot-button issues like abortion
or capital punishment what does it mean
to be conservative yeah traditional yeah
that's a good way to put it to the whole
wanting to hold on two ways that are
already established traditions that are
in place you're going to say about same
NS a traditional what the word tradition
is kind of important where else do you
associate with it
what I conservatives tend to resist yeah
now it gets really blurry today because
conservatives today are actually trying
to change things quite a bit you know in
part because liberalism in many many cat
many areas has become the status quotes
become conservative so these these words
get really messy and mixed up when we're
talking about the early 20th century and
the lead up to it what would it mean to
be conservative at that time even most
liberals of that time when strike us is
pretty conservative in many respects
that's something worth thinking about
the term that we're going to the we're
going to end up at our closing not so
much in this chapter but later chapters
to liberal is going to be from the
mentalist and in the nineteen early
1900s particularly in the 1920s there's
going to be a lot of conflict between
liberals or what are often called
modernists at that time and
fundamentalists and liberals are
basically going to win the institutional
battle to hold on to the churches and
who's in charge and particularly who's
in charge of teaching and seminaries
who's in charge of the leadership and
the fundamentalists are going to find
themselves sort of pushed out and
they're inform their own churches we're
going to see splits occur in some of the
main Protestant denominations and no not
fun not all conservatives are
fundamentalists as a matter of fact not
all biblical literalists not all people
who believe that the Bible is literally
true are fundamentalists there's that
there's a particularly narrow conception
of the turn
a precise conception of the term that
we're going to look at in what later
chapters but this is the main struggle
here and we're not going to really talk
that much about fun not on the side
because we want to focus out as the
liberal side so your book talks about
certain key themes and I listed them
here focus on process and progress and
growth not only in terms of the
individual but in terms of society in
terms of institutions to be a liberal at
the Act I'm meant to have this this
viewpoint that human beings have been
developing you know from the you know
prehistory through a number of different
stages and modern human beings
particularly modern European and
American human beings we're kind of at
the pinnacle of it things are just
getting better and better and better and
there was no kind of a monkey wrench
thrown into that the First World War and
you know later on especially with some
of the things that occurred in 30s and
40s but that was a very common view
point I think and when you have a a
process there's no radical jumps you
know things are ongoing think about it
classes for example the way you have to
set up this class is you have a lot of
writing assignments you know little bits
and pieces here and there so if you miss
one of them your grade doesn't
completely plumb it it's not like you're
some of you should be investing all of
your time in any one single writing
assignment putting all the edges into
that basket how do some people set up
their classes that would be very
different one paper due at the end or
three papers over the course of the
semester and everything is like back
loaded so that's the very last thing and
people start to panic because you got
you know several classes like that and
it tends to produce work that isn't
isn't very good
that would be discontinuity that would
be something different than process
process means you're like doing a bit
here a bit there if the change is kind
of gradual that's the way that these
people are seeing the religious process
so we're going back to that in a moment
eroding sharp lines or boundaries
liberals are often the ones to say well
how can we all just get along these
distinctions aren't really that
important and conservatives are usually
the one saying no these actually do
these these distinctions really do
matter we can't just get rid of them all
together so for think about for example
religious denominations you know if I
now you know where I hope you do what
differentiates Presbyterians from say
Baptists from Anglicans you can you can
set some dividing lines between them
they have to do with distinctives what's
distinctive to Presbyterians
predestination for example now do all
Presbyterians necessarily believe in
predestination I think quite a few of
them today don't and quite a few
Presbyterians the day in some of the
mainline churches which are all in one
big church presbyterian church USA will
could have awful lot like Methodists in
the United Methodist Church or people in
some of the other mainline churches
those those dividing lines get kind of
learn their felt to be less important
whereas a conservative presbytery cool
site know this we we don't agree on this
here would be a great example in terms
of Lutheran's years back the Catholic
Church and the largest Lutheran body in
the world signed a joint agreement on
declaration signed a joint agreement on
justification by faith which is one of
the key things that leisure is all about
right and they said well when we look at
the documents it kind of turns out that
maybe we work so
different you know and the dividing
lines weren't so sharp as we thought now
if you talk to a missouri synod lutheran
they will say we didn't sign that we
don't read out it really that we set
down a line in the scene so liberals
tend to erase lines in the sand you
could say biblical studies was a growing
discipline at the time and if you if you
were to take other religious studies
classes here at marys for instance on
the New Testament we're on the Old
Testament what you would find is you
would not be studying it from a
denominational perspective I wouldn't be
studying it as a Catholic Lutheran or
zone presbyterian you wouldn't even have
to be a committed Christian what you
would be doing is to be looking at the
texts and what the biblical scholars
have told us about the development and
history of these texts so I mentioned
this in a previous class Book of Isaiah
for example one of the longest books in
the Bible turns out he was probably
written according to modern biblical
studies the higher criticism it was
probably written by multiple authors not
just one guy whose name was Isaiah now
does that like sand bag or shipwreck
faith it really depends if your faith
depends on every single thing being just
the way that you thought it was that's
going to be a big problem that's going
to be a mind-blower realizing that the
different books of the Bible were
written by at different times by people
who have different perspectives of
things it doesn't necessarily mean that
you have to say it's not divinely
inspired it doesn't necessarily mean
that you have to say that God is not
involved in the process at all but
biblical studies would focus more on the
human element of it you know here's one
you know an example that comes up in the
book of Genesis there's two different
stories for the creation of human beings
in Genesis why are there two different
stories well one of the theories is that
each of these reflects a different
perspective one reflects a priestly
point of view and forget what the other
source was like a full point of view and
then they get brought together in one
single text so modern biblical studies
is taking off and it's particularly
taking off in German and whether you
realize it or not german university
education is really responsible for the
kind of education that we do today and
high rep your professors what kind of
degrees do they have hopefully they have
degrees right so every once in a while
you find out that they didn't do the
background check on somebody they don't
actually have a degree in what they say
they do it's happened more than I don't
know if it's a secure at marys but it's
happened in places where I've talked
before what kind of degree should they
have a BA you guys are working on this
shouldn't have to start what else ok
masters is that that's a good position
and if this were a hundred years ago
most of the people teaching would only
have a master's degree here in the
United States what do most of your
professors have I daughter song people
with mfa's and the yeah now where's the
PhD means doctorate philosophy and not
dissolve them study philosophy of course
not but it's sort of an honorific title
and in order to get a PhD you're going
beyond the master's thesis how many of
you are thinking about going to grad
school okay let me add to that how many
of you are thinking going to
professional school as well like law
school getting an MBA things like that
okay so quite a few of your going on to
graduate education at the Masters level
you produce some sort of artifact some
sort of research if you're doing a
creative thing like an MFA you create a
project and it takes a lot of time and
work mine is about 110 pages and that
was actually the second one
cuz I being in the first one and you
have to take some coursework and you
know probably a qualifying exam or
something like that yeah the phd level
how is that different you got takes more
coursework and by that time you might
actually be teaching these days what
else do you have to do at the phd level
what qualifies the people who are
teaching you actually they make a paper
and I think it offended yeah what's up
paper call citizens thesis is at the
Masters level dissertation dissertation
and a dissertation is a book a lot of
them actually get turned into the ones
that get published so my dissertation
was about 450 pages and it took me about
two years to write my media I actually
wrote about it on this guy breeze
blowing down his philosopher and
modernism and and Catholicism because he
was a Catholic thinker and I never
published it as it got way too big and
it was you know do this sprawling work
and I'm not very proud of it okay that
was a long time but once you actually do
that you're qualified you have your you
have to defend it of course and
sometimes they get rejected if they're
not any good devil comes from this
German system and a lot of Americans
their their work a lot of these graduate
degrees offered at American universities
at the time later on we copied the
German system pretty much wholesale so
they would go over to Germany the study
and that's where this hires criticism
was really taking hold so theologians
and philosophers and historians and
literary people they would go over to
Germany and they get exposed to all
these ideas and they come back and then
of course there you know once you learn
an idea you want to try to apply it you
want to start using it so that's that's
another key on evolution we're going to
talk about that a bit more I put that in
all caps because that turned out to be
sort of like that the rallying point
where the
conservatives and liberals really
fighting each other and store to some
degree today you know over what should
be taught in school nowadays it's
usually in terms of creationism vs.
evolution but that's that's coming from
this era and then an intense focus on
ethics so your book talks about some key
figures but I'm going to actually only
hit on a few of them one of the ones
that fits in with this notion of process
is this Horace Bushnell Ian he's a
Congregationalist who wrote this book
called the discourse on Christian
nurture now when you talk about a
nurturer what does that mean find your
at trivia I'm not actually a very
nurturing I you know I'm more of a
take-it-or-leave-it kind of guy oh like
there every step of the way like helping
them yeah that's a good way to put it
well like I'm you know think about a
coach who's like always there for you
and they're not you know they don't come
down on you and say you're doing it
wrong dummy they they're like you know I
think you know if you was you swimming
right I don't anything about swimming so
I'm going to make this on you know I
think you're what your stroke is like
this but you really want to be you know
putting your hand like that and they
like guide you through it that's being
here trick and it's bit by bit but step
by step by step and so bushnell is is is
undercutting this evangelical assumption
remember the evangelicals thought that
you you have to have a conversion
experience that's how you know you're
saved you have to you know have this
moment where you say come on Jesus you
know or welcome Lord or or I'm such a
you know a sinner and now I'm going to
be saved whatever it's great to be
there's a lot of different variations on
this there has to be some some Crocs
some crisis and Bushnell said no you
don't actually need that they can just
be this constant steady growth in
spirituality
he said you know this is only important
if you believe in original sin and he
de-emphasized original sin so what does
this lead to Bushnell talks and this is
you know above this Abronia sharp lines
as well orginal talks about the divine
in the human being in a complementary
relationship so that God's grace redeems
the imperfect realm of human activities
so what would it be like well it would
you know if you think about children for
example what are the important
institutions in a child's life okay
school what else family family of course
Church it because we're talking about
religion that's assuming they're going
to church and what else what if we get a
little bit bigger yeah now he's not that
concerned about that at the time but if
you're around today he'd be like looking
at social media and what it does and you
know television he probably would be
very happy you may reconsider some of
his ideas the general idea was that
through school through home through
church through society as a whole you
would take a child and bit by bit by bit
nurture them in Christianity so they
would never have to have this experience
of like feeling like they're you know
radically damaged and in need you know
some sort of fundamental change instead
it would just be this continual
progressive growth getting better and
better and better so that's that's these
two elements here the biblical studies
like I said the German universities were
really taking the lead with this yeah
what are your book characters this is
very nice assessment they regarded the
Hebrew and Christian scriptures not as a
modulus unified divinely revealed pair
of documents but rather is a collection
of religious texts have been written
edited that's very important
redacted and collected within their
respective communities over many many
centuries in so it talks a bit about
form criticism for criticism your book
doesn't they actually go to a detail
about it here's in a nutshell what they
would do inform criticism they would
focus on what's called the zinzin Laden
which means her like the the particular
kind of situation that a text was
written for so they would say this text
was coming out of this particular kind
of situation this can need oriented
towards this kind of audience it might
not be meant for this audience over here
it might not apply quite as well so this
goes against the notion that you can
just take the Bible is one big unified
document and just kind of pick out
whatever you like do like what they call
proof texting you know a lot of people
when they want to appeal to the Bible
they just start looking for a verse that
will sound sort of like what they want
to say that's proof texting the proof is
that you've got taps to back up what
you're saying it's a very layman's way
of putting this this would be a
rejection that this would be a more
sophisticated attitude Twitter so
liberals didn't see this is a big
problem they saw this as an affirmation
that God's mess that should not been
revealed in a static form but it put
through a process an ongoing process
this did not go over well with many
people who had a much more traditional
attitude towards toward Scripture so we
talked about this before if there's one
figure to associate with evolution even
though he of course did not come up with
the idea had been around for a long time
before him it's who its charles darwin
and darwin writes the origin of species
there's actually a reading group here at
on campus that every so often picks it
up and like actually reads it there's a
lot of people who talk a lot about
Darwin and evolution I never actually
read what the guy said you'd be
surprised it's not quite so clear cut in
some circumstances you know you'd say
the eye is difficult for me to explain
but he thought that he could provide
some pretty conclusive scientific
evidence that species developed over
time we talked about this before that's
a problem if you think that God created
them all at the beginning and they
haven't changed at all through time if
you have a more processed view not
really a problem for you as a matter of
fact most of the churches around the day
don't have a problem with evolution its
massive the minority of trenches that do
but that took a while to develop the
next book is kind of a bombshell because
it's about the descent of man there he's
saying that we're actually one of the
Apes so that goes against the notion
that human beings are somehow privileged
are special now like he says
conservatives protested the theory of
evolution derived deprived Humanity of
its unique character and God of a
special creative power it also went
against the literal accuracy of opening
chapters of Genesis and on a moral plane
what do you what's the word or not the
word what's the catch phrase that you
associate with Charles Darwin and
evolution survival of the fittest now
what does that mean in economic terms or
in the workplace yeah exactly and what
we call social Darwinism was something
that a lot of people embraced but a lot
of people were actually quite against it
as a matter of fact nowadays we
associate social Darwinism with
conservatives the conservatives of the
day we're against social Darwinism for
the most part it anymore progressives
behind it saying well you know the
weaker will get weeded out the ones who
are unfit to survive
not Lance this got applied by the way in
terms of race to wavy on you know what
the evidence would support their hopes
that you know all the inferior races and
you know where who was inferior really
depended on who was doing the talking
about this didn't that the inferior
races would be sort of weeding out over
time that was part of social Darwinism
that was sort of an illegitimate
extension of Darwin's theory into social
areas but it was closely associated with
with that now the other thing is this
focus on ethics and this is what leads
us now to the social gospel so your book
talks about this guy Walter option bush
who brought Jesus is teaching the beer
human experience in terms of the poor
starts up working in Hell's Kitchen
which you know nowadays we associate
that with the Gordon Ramsey show more
than anything else right but at that
time it meant the slums the real
hardcore poverty-stricken people will
kill you for you know your shoes kind of
swamps and he's carrying out ministry
they're trying to reach the people we've
seen his theory theme number times
training reaches people were unchurched
who are not being dealt with and so he's
looking particularly at who tend to be
the poor at this time there was some
what we call generational poverty
generational poverty is when your
parents reported grandparents are poor
you know all the way back as far as you
can remember you don't have the
resources that you know other people
sort of take for granted you don't
envision anything other other than that
for
so and so you stay poor and you probably
make this sort of bad life decisions
that will keep you poor but it wasn't so
much generational poverty who was coming
into the United States around this time
we had immigrants yeah and you know
American was going to flood it with
immigrants from all over the place
there's actually a great book out there
called how the Irish became white the
Irish were not considered white by my
white people at the time that a lot of
these developments in the 19th century
were taking place why not because if
while they were Catholic and they were
backwards Celts you know from the Irish
Isles and they spoke a weird kind of
jumbled up English if they spoke English
at all and they would work for you know
as cheap as possible they were like the
lowest class of society for a while yeah
at least you know New York and places
like that and eventually they they they
claw their way up there were a lot of
other cases like that slobs tennis
suspicion and prejudice against people
from Slavic countries other south
europeans like italians there's also
mexican immigration going on there's
also some very important immigration
happening within the United States about
this time as well it has to do the
African Americans where where most of
the African Americans located around the
time of the Civil War south south and
then what happens emancipation what
happens yeah so it's not just immigrants
from Europe or from other places it's
also migration coming up to you know to
the northern cities and this generates a
lot of horror people a lot of poor areas
so you know the social gospel the
emphasis is on this gospel part and you
know whenever you see gospel the odd
thing about this Jesus guy so you know
what was Jesus's attitude towards poor
people the ordinary Joe's they say come
back when you got some more money I
don't want you to church you're not
dressed right then I can find anything
like that in the Gospels what was his
attitude towards towards for his poverty
and towards report if you had to
generalize it a special care for like
skiing held up slightly above normal
people yeah the first shall be last the
last shall be first I mean it depends on
which verses for emphasizing right he
also didn't say do anything you want you
know it should be thrifty look at some
of the parables like in the talents all
right but you don't think about you know
the loaves and the fishes story is
apostles their way out the desert others
there's no fruit and as apostles were
like man what are we gonna do with this
crowd here everybody's here to listen to
you and nobody's got any food this is
you know who's going to turn cat ugly
why don't you send them you know to town
we get something some food says what I
want to faint along the way and then you
know you guys all know the story the
loaves and the fishes somebody's that
some boy has got a basket fit has some
wolves and they start passing around it
never ends up being exhausted and they
actually end up having everybody fed and
way more food than they started with
originally and what was the really key
thing of that thing Jesus says Jesus
takes pity on he says I don't want to
send them away hungry lest they think
you know thinked on the road I want to
take care of them and so for a lot of
Christians it was felt that look if
you're really a Christian and you've got
all these poor people then you want to
be orienting your Christian
worship your Christian service towards
the poor and so Rauschenbach talks about
that and another dimension of this would
be changing society what are some of the
things that keep people for just to
think about it in our own time time I
tracks yeah ok so how jobs keep ppl park
I don't know you don't make enough money
to you can't like my things you're like
yeah I want to you don't have the skill
set to like move up in the world yeah
once you get stuck with a with a job and
all the dependencies that go along with
that like having a car having to pay for
insurance having a place to live that
you got to pay rent on or pay property
taxes I or paying a mortgage on and then
start having kids it becomes very
difficult to move from one job to
another and there are you know programs
and opportunities to do that but for
many people even today really especially
today there's a lot of what we call
dead-end jobs and they're not dead end
jobs just because they're unsatisfying
they're dead end jobs because once you
get into them it's difficult to get
yourself out of them had to move up even
if you really want to you have to really
apply yourself people get depressed you
know we're actually at a point in time
now where there are people who have been
out of work for years we had right
before and don't take anything that you
yeah for a while they were to promise
I'm not going to take it out minimum
wage job but now they will there were a
lot of conditions like that and the
safety net that we we talked about the
day didn't really exist back then now
tent we have a sort of governmental and
state you know safety net churches by
the way still do massive charity
outreach in some some areas the churches
do more
the federal or state governments do as
far as like before but it was felt that
unless you actually change the rules of
the game change society you're just
going to be perpetuating poverty by
providing people with charity you really
have to transform things through through
what through through laws perhaps
through raising wages what else might
fit in their education you know even
things as simple as you might not
associate this with like changing
society but teaching people how to
parent well you know a lot of people are
in poverty because their parents don't
know how to parent that's not it by the
way before you know I'm sure somebody's
going like you know get angry on YouTube
say who are you to blame that but you
know the Sun say that's a soul cause but
these these sort of sort of programs
actually are quite effective you know
there's a program that would fit in with
this quite well I don't know if it
actually had a religious orientation
originally it was called reeti dad and
quite a few of the guys when I was
teaching in a maximum-security prison
would participate in this and what they
would do is they would send books to
these prisoners whose kids you know have
a dad in prison which puts them in a
pretty severe disadvantage in a lot of
respects and the dad would actually just
read the book to the kid Adam of your
tape recorded and then they'd send a
tape recording along back with the kid
and you might say well that's really
nice who cares it's just nice for that
that one little kid you get stuff or she
gets to hear their dad well it turns out
that father's involvement with a child's
life is one of the best predictors for a
whole bunch of things whether a child
flourishes or does poorly so if you were
to actually put together a program like
that that could actually be an
expression of the social gospel it would
make sense within that
for me it would be transformative so the
this the social gospel movement you know
gets bigger and bigger and here it
incorporates not only Protestants but
also some some Catholics your book
mentions Monsignor John Ryan who came up
with the notion of the just wage and
another thing that comes out of this is
a focus on social science when we say
social science what do we mean these are
often you know long together as the
social studies when you're in high
school here we have a college of social
sciences what what it what discipline
Sir Arthur yeah very good that's the
sociology yeah sociology that were you
essentially say like anthropology
anthropology fits in there as well I
don't do we have a program here in
anthropology I don't know we have a
specific one for it yeah I'm taking a
course honest I don't think so you don't
find so many of those programs did you
ever end up to nas NE says we do okay to
a certain extent economics depending on
how you're doing it could be understood
as a social science these these often
are criticized for being activists
disciplines or not just sticking to the
data but for trying to change things by
by accumulating the data and that has in
fact a lot of people in social sciences
do but that comes out of this so there's
what the book talks about as an alliance
between theology and social science and
it begins to take shape of the new field
of social ethics again the focus is on
saying we need to change society we need
to figure out how to make society better
so there's not going to be so many
people poor and stuck being poor for
their entire life and being cut off from
all the advantages that everybody else
enjoys and for Christians
this is again coming out of the gospel
imperative that's again why it's called
the social gospel so this needs to
what's eventually called the
institutional Church and the
institutional Church is in a certain way
a revival some of the things that the
churches used to do yeah in a certain
way it's a it's a new thing before the
government took over certain functions a
lot of charity was handled by churches a
lot of outreach to to poor people but it
was done generally in a non systematic
way so here's here's some examples of
things that they use this you know st.
George and the column you in Manhattan
did any of you guys from the city and
you know this this particular church st.
George II and the breath Allah meal
they'll offer weekly worship right which
churches do but they also extended their
professional staff and program and
physical plant to promote wide variety
outreach endeavors so what if these
include day care providing day care for
people why would that be important yeah
that allows like their parents to both
work yeah and you know where the kids
are there they're not getting in trouble
you know that can turn out to be the
make or break for a lot of families day
care is expensive you're going to start
realizing this when you start having
kids summer outings for poor urban
children why is that important taking
kids out of the city good experience
like my child side
yeah they can imagine something
different that's that's capable I was
just going to say like cultures them
they like learned there's more than just
like the city there's other parts like
life in the world it's easier to
envision yourself somewhere else when
you see in somewhere else I knew a
person who grew up in LA and she grew up
in LA in the 60s and she was dirt poor
and la smog was so bad at that time that
you I mean my pollution was banned to
you couldn't see the stars at night yeah
but the smog was just torn terrible as
well it was one of these sort of
programs they took a bunch of kids out
of the city she wasn't even Christian
she was a Jewish kid and they took him
into the foothills and she had a
religious experience because she saw the
stars actually for the first time when
she was in her teens and it was kind of
an awesome experience and a really
strucker's soon she realized you know
man I don't have to live like this this
is something is something better
educational training programs churches
do that as well why is that important if
you want to transform society why is
that they could we provide someone like
an opportunity like if someone can't
like afford education on their own if
you give it to them they can like get a
job there's something they don't like
that yeah I mean the government does
quite a bit of that stuff not if it's
not at this time though this time that
we're talking about the government
doesn't do any of that so church is
doing that it's really revolutionary its
paving the way for people to to do
things the book talks about this is
being part of a larger movement called
social Christianity and we've mentioned
the YWCA why did YWCA YMCA me for these
also Catholic and Jewish counterparts
urban gospel mission's of salvation army
these are all part of this larger effort
to buy Christianity in terms of society
and your book talks about the effects of
the social
it brought about a number of different
important changes some of which are
still around today we tend to see what
they call faith-based efforts as
something that the Conservatives are
mostly involved in really the religious
left has been doing this since the
social gospel movement started this is
an ongoing behind-the-scenes kind of
process it happens not just in
Louisville Protestantism but also the
Catholic Church there's a lot of Jewish
outreach things as well religious
organizations have been I've been doing
this sort of thing for quite some time
the last thing that your book really
talks about in this chapter is another
variety of Protestant liberalism and it
has to do with what's called modernism
so this would go to what my dissertation
actually focused on to a certain extent
although I was more focusing on Catholic
modernism and even if you haven't heard
this term used in religious contexts you
probably have a good idea about what
this means and you also want to be
careful with this modernism means a lot
of different things in a lot of
different areas so literature it means
something different in our that means
something different in architecture it
means something different in music it
means something different here we're
talking about in terms of religion and
the modernists were these people at
major universities and divinity schools
who started constructing a theology that
was based now in Revelation or reason
but directly on human religious
experience yeah your book doesn't
actually stress this well enough but
religious experience was understood
based on certain basic human needs which
include a need for the transcendent
people will people here's the amazing
idea all of us need to have some sort of
connection to something bigger than us
that provides us with me and some of us
are able to find this in our careers
some of us are able to find this in you
know family & relationships but one way
that people have traditionally found
this is in terms of religion and that's
the modernist sort of perspective they
ask where the religious impulse comes
from and then people get excited about
religion and they pass this stuff down
because they have religious experiences
if you don't actually have any sort of
experience you're probably going to be
kind of left cold now there are some
people who do to a lot of talking about
religion but don't have any basis in
experience but those people tend to be
you know less credible they tend to be
you know the ones that don't don't
produce a lot of so you know what would
be an example religious experience we
talked about the conversion experience
the feeling that one is somehow damaged
sinful tainted with with you know the
effects of original sin and along comes
Christ and through one's relationship
with Christ one is reborn one is renewed
one is redeemed one becomes a different
better kind of person that was a very
common religious experience so the
modernists are less interested in the
theology and they're more interested in
what does that actual experience like
what does it feel like under what
circumstances does it happen what kind
of people has happened in actual william
james american philosopher because
varieties of religious experience is
sort of a scientific study of this and
it's not aiming at the destruction of
supernatural faith but an appreciation
of what religion
so there's also a focus on the facts of
religion and there's a lot of different
ways in which this this takes shape your
book talks about you know the University
of Chicago is sort of leading the way
with this the school attrition personal
asst around Boston University and all
these people are interested in putting
the analysis of religious truth on an
experiential or empirical basis now what
form do you think this would take today
this is this merely historical or you
know you hear people say well this works
for me that's why I'm into this I wanted
to study this particular religious
movement and I found it merit and value
for me met my needs and produce good
effects in my life changed you know me
I'm not saying it as Universal validity
somebody else might have a totally
different need for a different kind of
thing but what worked for me was this
have you heard people talk like that
about not even necessarily religious but
transcendent experiences things that
give them life meeting that would be
sort of typical expressions of this view
I think a lot of the spiritual but not
religious people you know put that in
scare quotes because it's used so often
I'm spiritual but not religious a lot of
them could couldn't get behind this and
fit into this as well and this has its
origins in the early 20th century for
the most part early or the late 19th
century your book also talks about neo
orthodoxy but I'm going to skip over
that because it's talked about in a
later chapter